pis si mon genou droit une position qui
vous transporte en 2008 on est là au
championnat universitaire américain
simin que vous la reconnaissez là mais
keith bogans garçons à côté de lui là
qu'il fait bon coin super six comme ça
oubliez marc chabot est chez nous et
avec nous qui a joué avec stephen curry
à des métiers un petit gars sont chez
nous je veux pas voir la condescendance
et vous avez vu votre coéquipier votre
ex coéquipiers jouer est ce qu'il était
à la hauteur où les raptors ont vraiment
été meilleur parce que là vous commentez
rds dont vous avez les yeux braqués sur
tous les écrans et les reprises
oui nicklaus a fait de l'excellent
travail a juste pour planifier la juste
pour vous pour calibrateur super forme
de la façon qu'ils ont fait qu'ils ont
performé
on avait un plan de match direct pour
arrêter steve qu'eric roy thompson on
sait qu'à 22 ans n'a pas joué les
blessés il est un joueur qui en émergent
d'alan billis vous faut penser en
considération le fait qu'il n'a pas joué
ça fait mal aux oies rieuses
mais en gros le plan de match des
meneurs c'était de ralentir cette écurie
croyais thomson est aussi de trouver des
façons de marquer avec les autres
joueurs autres que cruise line up parce
qu'on le savait steve que entraîneur
cumulés il va essayer de ralentir lui
aussi croit la nuque qui est un des
moeurs performant des séries minatoires
jusqu'à maintenant
steve que dit qu'ils n'avaient pas peur
des raptors il va réviser ces
impositions cela dit les wraps tueuse
dans leur parcours vers cette finale du
championnat une première pour eux
n'avaient pas l'habitude de prendre
l'avancé dans les matchs où va la jouer
à la fin du troisième quart temps 44e
cas où le vent tournait alors qu'ils
aient raison qu'il avance dès le départ
ils ont gardé pas mal l'avant ce oui moi
je m'attendais début de match l'un des
orateurs habituellement quand on est
nerveux
on recense dans l'air les partisans
étaient tous très très très nerveux
c'est comme ça à chaque début de ronde
pour les réacteurs depuis le début des
séries
on perd souvent notre première partie
dans le coup cette partie là on avait un
sens de confiance
on croyait que on avait la chance de
gagner cette partie là et le plan de
match était vraiment fait pour gagner
le fait aussi qu'on a un joueur comme
croire honneur qui est posée qui est
confiant pour vous
qui à part des dérangés par la pression
de jouer un dans une scène aussi grosse
le vécu avec les spurs de san antonio
dans le passé alors juste le fait
d'avoir cette expérience là je pense que
ça le juste sécuriser la majorité des
joueurs des riders ou si la foule une
chose dont on a beaucoup parlé et qui
est extra terrain c'est toute la
controverse autour de drake est ce que
c'est une stratégie pour enlever de la
pression sur les joueurs partent parce
que pendant ce temps là les les
les projecteurs sont braqués sur lui et
non sur les länder de l'est fred dalle
led et compagnie ça se peut que ce soit
stratégie on le sait que les raptors en
général le fait d'avoir djuric à toronto
le nommé ambassadeur
ça a été une stratégie de marketing
juste pour amener la visibilité à
toronto et de l'intérêt à la franchise
avec tout ça je dirais il faut juste se
concentrer sur le basket et le fait que
les réacteurs sont en train d'accomplir
quelque chose qui ait jamais été vu une
équipe performante au niveau canadien
aux basques dans l'année j'en ai passé
dès vendredi soir le long des cours de
basque
on a l'impression de boucliers ce qu'on
veut aux joueurs quand le joueur est
dans la partie
il entend pas est ce qu'on peut dire la
même chose quand cédric qui vient vous
enlever des cheveux ou des trucs comme
ça
probablement mais on a des joueurs des
fois qui on le sait mais avec les médias
sociaux
mais même les joueurs qui ont des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
les suivent les ses joueurs qui font des
millions de dollars pour quand même
réagir sur les médias sociaux ils vont
se faire déconcentrer par des gars comme
zurich
ça dépend de la capacité mentale de
certains de ses joueurs il y en a qui
l'on gagne qu'ils l'ont pas ça va être
intéressant
c'est justement pour le reste des séries
on a vu dans les journaux ce matin à san
francisco le vent tourne
ils ont un peu plus peur de toronto ce
qui n'était pas le cas hier matin va le
premier match votre prédiction
ben moi je l'aï dit à plusieurs reprises
la prédiction c'est qu'il ya plus vous
gagnez 100 ans est bon ben vous l'avez
écrit merci beaucoup merci